البدايه من تطورات ملف اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
عبر البحر الاسود بين روسيا واوكرانيا حيث
اعلن عن تمديد الاتفاق لمده ثلاثه اشهر
واصطى ترحيب اممي وتاكيد روسي على ان
موسكو تسلم الضمانات الامميه بشان رفع
القيود عن صادراتها في اطار صفقه الحبوب
اللي هي المتابعه ينضم الينا من ثياب
مراسل الجزيره المعتز بالله حسن ومن موسكو
مراسله الجزيره رانيا دريدي ومن انقر
مراسله الجزيره فرح زمان شوقي والبدايه
معك فرح اذا الرئيس التركي
تمديد هذا الاتفاق اليوم ماذا في تفاصيل
بالفعل وسيله ليس فقط الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان وانا ما ايضا وزاره الدفاع
التركيه اصدرت قبل ساعه تقريبا من الان
بيانا قالت فيه بان اجتماعا عقد على مدى
يومين امس واليوم بين الاطراف الاربعه
روسيا اوكرانيا الامم المتحده وتركيا
الراعي الرئيس لهذه المبادره بحث هذا بحثت
هذه الاجتماعات التي جرت على شكل ثنائي
ورباعي مساله تمديد هذه الاتفاقيه ووضعت
على الطاوله
مساله الضمانات وبعد التدابير المتعلقه
بتصدير الحبوب الى دول دون اخرى بمعنى هنا
الدول الافريقيه وزاره الدفاع التركيه
تؤكد بان هذه الاجتماعات جرت بشكل ايجابي
واسفرت عن تمديد هذه الاتفاقيه ل120
يوما وهو ما اعلن عنه في وقت سابق الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان والذي اكد بان
تركيا ستقوم بتحويل بعض هذه الحبوب الى
دقيق وستقوم بتصدير الى همم دول ثانيه من
قبيل الدول الافريقيه وهو احد الشروط
الروسيه كما كانت انقره قد اعلنت في وقت
سابق تركيا التي كانت تتحدث عن احتمال
تمديد تلقائي لهذه الاتفاقيه او تمديدها
لمده عام تتحدث اليوم عن تمديد ل 120 يوما
فقط وهو ما يعني وجود بعد الخلافات
السياسيه المرتبطه بالضمانات والشروط
تحديدا تلك الروسيه الاتفاقيه ستستمر ل120
يوما وذلك بعد تصدير اكثر من احد عشره
مليون طن من الحبوب عبر الموانئ الثلاثه
التي ذكرت في الاتفاقيه التي تم التوصل
اليها برعايه الامم المتحده في وقت سابق
في اسطنبول عبر اكثر من 500 سفينه تم
تفتيشها في اسطنبول قبل البحر في البحر
الاسود وتامل تركيا في الفتره المقبله ان
تسفر الجهود الدبلوماسيه عن عدم
للتطبيق هذه الاتفاقيه كما جرى في وقت
سابق من الشهر الجاري وسيله نعم اتحول
اليك المعتز بالله كيف تستقبلت خبر تمديد
هذه الاتفاقيه
كيف هي اول من اعلن عن تمديد هذه
الاتفاقيه حيث اعلن
الرئيسكي عبر حسابه في تويتر عن ان
الاتفاقيه ستمدد 120 يوما وقال وقت اعلانه
ان الشركاء سيتحدثون عن هذه المعلومات
لاحقا هذا يؤشر الى سعاده كيف بتمديد هذه
الاتفاقيه خصوصا وانها اتفاقيه مهمه اولا
لمحصورها ثانيا هي مهمه اقتصاديا لهذا
البلد لكن هناك رغبه في ان لا تقتصر هذه
الاتفاقيه على 120 يوما فقط هي تريدها على
الاقل لعام هذا ان لم تكن اتفاقيه مستمره
همم على الرغم من مسار الحرب ايا كان هي
تريد هذه الاتفاقيه ان تستمر وبالتالي هي
تحدثت عن ضروره هذا الاستمرار في
الاتفاقيه هناك تاكيد على ان بالامكان
اضافه موانئ جديده لهذه التي وتحديدا نحن
نتحدث عن موانئه مدينه ميكولايت نحن نعلم
ايضا ان بناء قدس هو يعمل تقريبا حوالي
30% من طاقته فقط هناك همم اعمال اوكرانيه
بان يزداد ايضا هذا العمل في هذا الميناء
هي تحدثت ايضا كيف عن انها مستعده
للمساهمه في ازاله كافه
العقبات امام عملي مركز التنسيق المشترك
وبالتالي بالنسبه لكيف هو امر مهم هذه
الاتفاقيه وهي رحبت باستمرارها وتامل في
ان تكون مستمره فتره اطول من ذلك
في موسكو رانيا روسيا تتحدث عن تلقيها
ضمنات اماميه هل من توضيحات اكثر بهذا
الخصوص
يعني وسيله نحن نعلم ان روسيا ومنذ يعني
التوقيع على هذه الاتفاقيه وهنا لابد من
الاشاره والتفكير بان ااا مبادره البحر
الاسود او ما يسمى الحاليا صفقه الحبوب
تضم تضم باندين اساسيين وبحسب موسكو هما
حزمه واحده شامله اييي يعني مرتبطان ولا
يمكن تنفيذ احد البنود وتجاهل البند الاخر
وهو ليس فقط تصدير الحبوب من الموانئ
الاوكرانيه بل وايضا حصول روسيا على
امكانيه تصدير همم اسندتها ومحاصيلها
زراعيه للاسواق العالميه همم يعني انطلاقا
من ذلك روسيا اليوم تتحدث عن انها حصلت
على ضمانات روسيا كانت معترضه على الكيفيه
التي تم خلالها تنفيذ هذه الصفقه خلال
الفتره الماضيه يعني وهذا بدوره كان يمكن
ان يؤثر على القرار الروسي المتعلق بتمديد
هذه الصفقه ولكن اليوم خارجيه بالفعل اكدت
انها همم يعني توافق على تمديد هذه الصفقه
وذلك انطلاقا ادتني قاد اولا الضمانات
الضمانات تتعلق بالدرجه الاولى برفع كل
العوائق والحواجز التي تقف امام الصادرات
الروسيه للاسواق العالميه النقطه الثانيه
وهي حديثه الخارجيه الروسيه في بيانها عن
ان النتائج الوسطيه تدل على ان الامم
المتحده بالفعل باتت تنفذ التزاماتها في
اطار هذه الصفقه فيما يتعلق بالبند الروسي
من هذه الصفقه فيما يتعلق بازاله العواقب
والعقوبات المفروضه على روسيا اذا روسيا
اشارت الى انها خلال الفتره المقبله همم
120 يوم وهي الفتره التي تم تمديد الاتفاق
هذه الاتفاقيه لها في خلال هذه الفتره
روسيا ست- تؤكد على ضروره تنفيذ باقي
الالتزامات ورفع كل العقوبات والعوائق
التي همم يعني همم
تفرضها الدول الغربيه على صادرات الاسمده
سلعه الزراعيه الروسيه هنا ورد التفكير
بان الخارجيه الروسيه على لساني نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه تحدث ان هناك
280,000 طن من الاسمده الروسيه حتى هذه
اللحظه لا تزال عالقه في الموانئ
الاوروبيه لا تستطيع روسيا ارسالها الى
الدول الافريقيه وهنا كانت روسي قد تعهدت
بارسالها مجانا وهذه المشكله لابد من حلها
وان روسيا تنظر خلال الفتره المقبله وايضا
مساله مصير هذه الاتفاقيه على ما يبدو
وفقا لكل هذه التصريحات الصادره من روسيا
يتوقفوا على هذه الجزئيه الجزئيه اخرى
يعني مدى النجاح الصفقه في المرحله
المقبله التي يعتمد عليها ومساله استخدام
الممر الان من قبل القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه روسيا شدت على هذه الجزئيه في
بيان الخارجيه الروسيه اشاره لانها ستواجه
اي محاولات من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
لاستخدام هذا الممر الامن لاهداف عسكريه
لاستفزازات عسكريه ستواجهه بطريقه حازمه
همم
ان روسيا كانت قد علقت قبل فتره العمل
بهذه اتفاقيه بعد انتهاك هذه الجزئيه على
وجه التحديد وسيله شكرا جزيلا لك يا رانيا
مدريدي من موسكو واشكرك كذلك لمعتز بالله
حسن من كاف وفرح زماننا شوقي من انقره